[Music]
thank you all for coming tonight we're
gonna talk about a very serious subject
the situation that we face with
antibiotic resistant bacteria
antibiotics or once the the Silver
Bullet that seemed to be able to cure
just about everything now we look at
23,000 antibiotic resistant bacterial
infections every year so let me
introduce you to our panelists our first
participant is the director of the
Wisconsin Institute for discovery at the
University of Wisconsin Madison she was
a science advisor to President Barack
Obama
please welcome Jo Handelsman our next
participant is a professor at
Rockefeller University where he is head
of the laboratory of bacterial
pathogenesis and immunology please
welcome Vincent Fischetti our next
participant is an associate professor of
amino Biology and microbial pathogen is
at the Salk Institute
please welcome Janelle Ayers our next
participant is the Abaddon associate
professor at Rockefeller University
please welcome Sean Brady and finally
the singer professor of medicine in
microbiology and the director of the
human microbiome program at NYU School
of Medicine
please welcome Martin Blaser so I
thought that maybe a way to start would
be to to show a video this was an
experiment that was done at Harvard
where basically scientists created at
serve a gigantic petri dish sort of kind
of the size of an air-hockey table
basically and they seeded it with
bacteria on either side and then
basically laced it with antibiotics
starting at the edge with pretty mild
levels and then as you go further in it
gets more and more deadly until the
central band has a thousand times the
lethal dose for e.coli it's
really kind of mind-blowing we're gonna
see the bacteria so just sort of hanging
out there now they're multiplying this
is sort of time-lapse so when they hit
that point what they're encountering
that as antibiotics and then how are
they getting past it I mean you can see
them yeah it takes a little bit of time
and what they're waiting for is growth
of one or a very small number of cells
in the population that are already
resistant and so although there were
many many billions of cells crossing the
plate probably one in a million would
have resistance to the antibiotic so
they're dividing and one in a million
what just happens to gain this power to
get past it well they always had the
power it was pre-existing in the
population but then when the whole
population is the rest of the population
is stopped by the antibiotic because
they're inhibited by it then those few
that are resistant start proliferating
and then they take over and that's
exactly what it looks like in similar
terms when it's in the body you know you
take an antibiotic and most of the
bacteria will die but there will be
pre-existing mutants in the population
that are resistant that's great well not
great but it's amazing it is definitely
not great ya know don't get me wrong we
think of antibiotics as as the sort of
this heroic triumph of science I mean
how did how do we get to enjoy the
benefits of antibiotics what I mean how
did that begin well it started with a
chance discovery from by Sir Alexander
Fleming in the UK who found a fungus on
his plate
that was clearly inhibiting growth of
Staphylococcus on the petri dish and he
recognized what it was that this was a
compound that was diffusing into the
agar and determined that it was what we
now know of as penicillin but it was
many years before it could be used in
any kind of broad scale way because he
discovered that in 1929 and by the start
of World War two we still were not using
antibiotics
and they weren't in general use why not
I mean you you discover a drug you know
put it into practice I mean what was the
holdup they couldn't make enough of it
that fungus produced some but not enough
to go into large-scale production and so
during the war a scientist named Ken
Draper was work for the USDA in Peoria
and he decided as a war effort to put
out the call for penicillin producing
strains of Penicillium mold so he told
everybody in in Peoria to collect as
many fruits and vegetables with that
green blue fuzzy thing that you see on
your bread and fruit to bring those to
his lab and people did and he had this
large collection and it turned out it
was his own technician who has gone down
in history as moldy Mary now her name is
actually Mary hunt and she brought in
the winning cantaloupe and it had a
strain of Penicillium mold that produces
more penicillin than any other natural
strain to this day and so they started
they moved it right into commercial
production and started pumping out large
amounts of penicillin and they had
enough to be able to ship it the
penicillin to the troops in Europe and
so World War Two was the first war in
which more people died directly of
bullets and bombs than of the infections
that accompanied them Wow so and then
once once the war is over then
antibiotics start to become or just a
general medicine for the public in
general right yeah and at the same time
there was interest in soil bacteria that
produced antibiotics and and then after
the war there was just this explosion of
knowledge of people culturing organisms
from the soil screening them for
antibiotics and then moving into
production and so we had dozens of
antibiotics coming onto the market in
the next decades and Shawn I mean how
would you serve describe like they'd
serve the overall benefit of these
discoveries of penicillin and some of
these other early antibiotics I mean
what happen overall like in terms of
lives saved or so on what are we looking
at in terms of the scale of this I think
one of the figures is that Penniston
alone has saved 100 million lives and
that's penicillin alone yeah so if you
think about that single picture that Joe
talk you can see it in almost any
microbiology textbook that
probably saved more lives than anything
in the history of science of do you want
one kind of the thing in your office you
should hang that picture as a scientist
because it's made a larger impact on
human health than anything but but that
that whole discovery even today we're
still using those antibiotics so so
that's the initial discovery then you
think about almost everything that came
out of what we call the golden age of
antibiotics the 40s 50s and 60s
so people were finding things not just
on cantaloupe but in other culturing
soil bacteria largely in finding
antibiotics almost every class of
antibiotics that we used today was
discovered in that that time period we
have relied on antibiotic defense really
of those molecules and continuing using
versions of those molecules up until
today and that's why we're in the
position we are today we we've largely
ceased discovering antibiotics after the
Golden Age the late 60s early 70s
because we thought we were done we
thought we had solutions to these
problems is how good those initial
discoveries were how about how much
impact they made on human health vitsin
what's your sense of like when it
started to become clear that things
weren't going so well like when do you
think that the sort of the scientific or
medical community said I think we have a
problem well that happened pretty
quickly I mean we were seeing resistant
organisms to penicillin early on it was
it started like a matter of a few years
after no it's probably a year or two
after the introduction of Penance
exactly you are I receive early stages
of resistance but you know was it an
organism here an organism there but but
it was occurring at that time
mm-hm and it's been occurring at an
accelerated rate since then so Marty I
mean what do you think is what would you
say would be like like one of the main
factors that explains sort of how we got
to this point in terms of resistance
like what are we doing that is causing
all of these bacteria now to be just so
dangerous yeah so the short answer is
that Darwin was right and that is that
there is survival the fittest it's its
selection we are using
antibiotics in in such magnitude because
of the miraculous nature of antibiotics
both the public and the profession says
well why don't we just treat this person
with antibiotics even if their symptoms
are minimal so there's enormous pressure
selective pressure of antibiotic use and
it's just it's just a mathematical
certainty that there will be resistance
but it's not linear it's it's geometric
mm-hm because of the properties of a
bacteria growing yes but you have to
remember that bacteria come but most of
them come from the soil and antibiotics
are in the soil so they've learned for
millions of years how to deal with
antibiotics so the systems are there as
long as you if you've exposed them to
antibiotics
those systems become heightened then
become resistant so they've seen these
drugs or in similar drugs or or
antibiotics type molecules for hundreds
and hundreds of thousands and millions
of years Marty you've also been talking
a lot and writing a lot about the fact
that our antibiotics are not precision
weapons that you know you use them
against you know e coli emerge her so on
but that's not the only thing that's
going to affect so so antibiotics came
of age when we were when we were really
trying to eliminate these bad pathogens
but no one really considered what was
the effect of the antibiotics are the
normal bacteria living in the body the
normal bacteria that we call the
microbiome but now it's clear that that
when you take an antibiotic for a skin
infection or a longer urinary tract
infection that antibiotic is getting
everywhere in the body and it is
selecting for resistant organisms in
that body this is suppressing some
organisms and other organisms are coming
up and maybe some organisms are becoming
extinct as well so these are organisms
that we might actually depend on it
might be actually beneficial for us
and so in fact we know that one of the
main defenses against infection are our
residual our normal organisms they're
there they're the coast guard they are
protecting against invaders they don't
want to share their turf and fifty years
ago was shown that if you pretreat mice
or other laboratory animals with
antibiotics and then give them a
pathogen like Salmonella the the level
of Salmonella that it takes to kill the
mouse goes down by four logs you know by
ten thousand Falls mmm so Shawn I mean
someone might say like well we have any
of all these gigantic pharmaceutical
companies there's lots of money that
they can throw at the problem you know
there was penicillin and then there were
other things I can think of mice in and
you know you know science marches on so
so we've got like more in the pipeline
right that's the unfortunate thing
we have almost nothing in the pipeline
almost nothing you can you can ascribe
that to a number of different reasons we
don't get it a crisis because of one
thing that we get it because many things
came together that we probably didn't
foresee one of them being that our first
round of antibiotics worked so well
right that Golden Age of antibiotics we
were describing them people thought we
were done and so over the next ensuing
30 years antibiotic discovery programs
both in academic and industrial settings
largely shut down and so there are
almost no farmer school industries that
are putting at least the effort they
used to put in to finding antibiotics
the second thing is then if we've been
using antibiotics the same ones for 30
years it means they don't cost us
anything anymore they're all generic so
you can get an antibiotic for somewhere
between 3 and 20 cents a day in many
parts of the world so now you have an
infrastructure that doesn't exist and
you have a financial structure that
doesn't support the development of
antibiotics so we are at a certain point
trying to figure out how to restart that
farmer school industry and how to make
it worthwhile to restart it and
absolutely some major things changed
it's in direct competition with chronic
disease which is much more lucrative for
the companies because the drug you take
for the rest of your life is obviously
going to make them more money than a
drug you take for five days and then
stop and so even even now with the
crisis that we all know we're in very
few companies want to move back into
that area and what they're doing is
taking a drug that worked became
organism becomes resistant and they just
make a modification on that drug it's
cheaper for them to do that than to
start from the beginning and now the
virus can be
resistent much more rapidly so they work
for maybe a year or two and then they
can't use them anymore money and then
there's yet another problem and that is
that bacteria don't respect borders and
so what that means is that if a
resistant organism arises in another
country like India or China it doesn't
take too long for it to come over here
and because antibiotics are so
inexpensive and because people think
that they're so miraculous in many of
these countries people are able to get
antibiotics over-the-counter no
prescription necessary parents are
giving their kids ten courses of
antibiotics a year in some recent
studies funded by the Gates Foundation
tremendous antibiotic pressure very low
cost but somebody's making money on
those antibiotics resistant organisms
are arising and then they were there
crossing all over the world so this so
this sort of cheap marketplace of
antibiotics over counter and sone is
even helping to drive on yeah the whole
antibiotic market is broken the
antibiotics in one sense are too cheap
and and and are therefore overused and
abused and on the other hand there
there's no incentive to create new
antibiotics that we want to keep and put
in reserve for important infections
which won't affect tens of millions of
people so there isn't that market so the
the market the economic model for
antibiotics is just broken it's okay
just to put numbers on that right yeah
the most recent they're gonna differ a
little bit but let's say there's six
most recent antibiotics that came to
market made about ten million dollars
each last year ten ten million each
right okay that seems like a lot of
money but just let's say you've done all
the clinical trials you need and now you
need to synthesize on production scale
and antibody it's a hundred fifty
million dollar investment all right and
the reason these things make so little
money is you don't want to use them you
don't want to use in this frontline
defense right you want to put them in
reserve until you absolutely need them
and so where's the incentive if if
forget the hundreds of millions you put
into development just to make the thing
cost you ten times which you can sell it
for so for a year we really have to
rethink how
how we market these things how we as a
community decide we're gonna put
antibiotics in reserve and put an
upfront kind of realization that these
things are there we need to pay for them
as a community because we're gonna need
them someday all right so let's let's
brighten things up a bit by like I think
because you know you folks are actually
working on things so maybe we'll start
we'll start with antibiotics themselves
with new antibiotics so with Joe and
Shawn's work so so so you've been going
back to the soil I mean this the soil
that brought us all these original drugs
you think you think there are more there
for us to find I do so for a long time I
went to other methods for antibiotic
discovery and you'll hear about some of
those that sean's developed soon but the
reason I did that was that there was
some references from the 90s that said
that the soil was mined it was fully
tapped and I've gone back to the data
and I can't find the data and so now I
question whether that's really true
because in the ensuing decades my lab
just spontaneously discovered
antibiotics from novel antibiotics from
soil that hadn't been discovered and we
weren't even looking in some cases and
so it just occurred to me one day wait a
minute it's not mine if we're finding
them and so that's the approach we're
taking is going back and asking what is
the frequency of new compounds there was
one paper that said the the rediscovery
rate would be 99% so if he found a
hundred compounds 99 of them would be
already known well that's actually not
so bad if it's true because we can look
at a lot more than 100 compounds with
today's methods but but I'm not even
sure that that's true because it wasn't
really based on at least published data
maybe somebody in a pharmaceutical
company has the data but we haven't seen
it so are there particular places that
you like to go look for new antibiotics
in a particular soil that is you you you
like or is it just in your backyard well
we were looking across the world so we
have a worldwide network of
undergraduate students undergrads
yes undergraduates who are a fantastic
and very creative workforce
so we developed a course that is known
as the small world initiative
and it's taught in 15 countries and all
over the United States and about 10,000
students a year take the course and they
dig up soil from whatever environment is
interesting to them and they come up
with more interesting reasons that I
ever would for why environment is
interesting and and so they have this
great variety of soils they're isolating
very interesting antibiotic producing
organisms and now we have to go into the
next stage which is figuring out what
antibiotics are produced so we think
that you know if we have 10,000 students
each one gets at least ten antibiotic
producing organisms per year that's a
lot of candidates and so if we can crank
through enough of them even if that 1%
rediscovery or by 9% rediscovery rate is
correct we still have a lot of new
compounds to look at so Shawn I mean
what kind of approach are you taking to
searching for these these new
antibiotics so about 20 years ago now I
guess Joe and and a few other people
we're thinking along these ideas
thinking about is there a reservoir and
soil still of natural products and the
thing that percolated to the top of the
thinking of these people was that
there's data from an even longer ago
maybe 120 years ago that it appears we
don't culture most of the bacteria out
of the environment that actually the
bugs we've been playing with represent a
small fraction of the bacteria in the
environment so let me ask you so if
you'd like take a sample of you know a
little sample of soil first of all like
how many microbes are in there and how
much DNA are you talking about that
you're looking at from all of them so it
depends on whose numbers let's say
there's thousands maybe 10,000 different
microbes of which we culture about one
percent just one percent just one
percent again people have done better
nowadays it but they but they don't
solve the other problem which is even if
we can culture bacteria we don't turn on
their genes
all right so even if you can bring back
to here in the lab they don't know how
to turn on the genes they're gonna make
antibiotics for us and so what we want
to do is just look at their DNA and you
can get huge amounts of DNA at least on
the context of molecular biology out of
a single kind of gram of soil and so
it's the coming together of this idea
that we can
culture bacteria we can sequence their
genomes and we can we can mess with
genes right genes and ways that we can
turn them on it really allows you to
untap this reservoir that's been it's
been untapped or untapped mm-hmm so so
Vincent I wanted to kind of shift gears
here and look at a way of dealing with
bacteria that's totally doesn't involve
antibiotics at all there's and this is
this is kind of a long-running idea of
basically sending the enemies of
bacteria against them I mean can you
explain the idea of the this kind of
approach was sometimes called phage
therapy
well phage therapy actually started
before antibiotic therapy so it was
discovered by torte about a hundred
years ago discovered up he had a a
vessel and he it was in Cloudy with
bacteria and suddenly it disappeared
just disappeared in his eyes and he said
something's in there that kill the
bacterium figured out that it was it was
a virus a virus and only infected
bacteria bacteria phage it's called and
that started a revolution at the time he
used phage through to control infection
there's well before antibiotics so these
viruses they're fact they're known as
bacteria failures they're specific so so
what are we looking at so the blue thing
is bacteria and little thing is the
bacteria and the ring around that is the
cell wall now the bacteria when it
attaches it injects its DNA into the
cell and once that DNA gets into the
cell it takes over the cell for the
production of new virus particles and
once those virus particles are produced
the phage have a problem they have to
get out of that organism and they solve
the problem by producing an enzyme
called a licen that that drills a hole
in the cell wall and since the pressure
inside the bacteria is greater than the
external environment the organism
explodes and releases the back the
bacteria phage that have been produced
in the environment and that's phage
therapy using those phage to kill the
organism directly what we've done is now
taken that enzyme this
agains I'm that drills a hole in the
cell wall we can produce it recombinant
Li and when you add that enzyme
externally it does precisely what it did
from the inside drills a hole in the
wall membrane externalizes and kills the
organism so we've developed the enzyme
but that the phage now uses to release
its progeny phage you could use phage
themselves and that's called phage
therapy as a means to control bacteria
but you can use the enzyme to accomplish
the same thing I mean there are
particular species of phages that can go
after a particular species of bacteria
they're very specific that's the problem
with phage therapy is that they're
highly specific for the organism that
you're going after so so in order to
kill for exams of staph aureus you'll
need to produce a cocktail of maybe five
or six or ten or fifteen phage to get
around the chance of organisms becoming
resistant because the bacteria become
resistant very rapidly to phage so
they're getting resistant to the phages
as well as antibiotics they're just
evolving but that's that's the normal
system uh-huh the phage are trying to
get into the organism the bacteria
trying to keep them out so that balance
has been going on for a billion years
nobody wants to win that war phage don't
want to win because if they win all is
gone if the bacteria win well they can't
get enough DNA into them to modulate
their their their DNA themselves right
cuz bacteria taking in they're taking in
DNA and so they need that that that
acquisition of phage DNA that doesn't
kill them that allows them to pick up
genes if they allows them to survive
much more rapidly so then there's this
molecule that phage make this enzyme
called license right and so you want to
just try just using licen rather than
the whole virus yep we've been using
license for almost 20 years now
we have license and the the beauty of
license that they're very specific for
the organism we don't see resistance
we've never seen resistance we've been
doing this for twenty years
they cannot become resistant for license
because they have to remodel their cell
walls so it would take them a very long
time
come resistance probably hundreds of
years before they become resistant to
actual license and I think we have a
video actually showing those are anthrax
organisms and we've added license to
them and you can see what happens to
them this is real time they just explode
disappear so you can take 10 million
organisms in a test tube and add up 5
few micrograms of licen within a couple
of minutes they're gone so it works
quite well we have enzymes and they're
quite specific so you're you don't run
into the problem the antibiotic problem
where you kill everything your normal
floor and the kind the organism you're
trying to kill they're quite so you this
the answer that the staff enzyme will
kill staff anthrax enzyme kills anthrax
so you your your targeted killing you're
not affecting your normal floor so why
isn't everybody well I mean what's the
what are the challenges that you face
we're in clinical trials right now you
are phase two phase one showed that it
was quite safe but we're in phase
through in the hospitals about a hundred
and seventeen patients we should be done
by the end of this year treating MRSA
infections and endocarditis mersa
septicemia and endocarditis heart
infections heart valve infections and
and septicemia bacteremia and we'll know
by the end of the year so you know I
mean you had touched on this earlier
about you know maybe paying more
attention to our own sort of host health
in terms of dealing with these
infections and you know you're you've
been doing a lot of research into into
tolerance maybe you could sort of
describe serve the overall idea that
you're pursuing and then how do you know
what how that might translate into an
actual treatment for for a patient sure
yeah so I think the what is evident to
me with our perspective and developing
antibiotics and antibiotic history and
the approaches that have been described
by my fellow panelists is that they're
all based on the the question of
how do we kill microbes and developing
ways to kill microbes and we are
approaching this from a different
perspective we actually want to
understand what it takes to enable a
patient to return back to a healthy
state and to survive infectious diseases
and there's we I talked about sepsis and
how in sepsis and this is the case with
other infectious diseases as well
there's significant physiological damage
that occurs and that leads to
physiological dysfunction and in order
for a patient to return to a healthy
state and to survive an infection they
have to be able to you have to be able
to alleviate that damage that's occurred
and and restore the patient back to
normal physiological function and our
assumption is if we just kill the
pathogen we should be able to do that
but that's not necessarily the case
you can have patients where antibiotics
are effective in them but the
physiological damage that they've
endured kills the the patient anyways
and so there's we are taking a variety
of approaches to understand if our body
encodes ways to protect us from
infectious diseases by promoting health
and alleviating physiological damage and
about 10 years ago now we discover that
in addition to our immune system which
protects us from infections by killing
pathogens we've discovered that we
encode a distinct defense strategy that
we call the co-operative defense system
and this is a defense system that is
essential for us to survive infections
and it protects us by executing what we
call tolerance mechanisms or disease
tolerance mechanisms and these are
mechanisms at our bodies and code that
alleviate physiological damage during
microbial interactions and so these are
mechanisms that promote our health
without killing the pathogen so you can
induce these tolerance responses
a host and they will be perfectly
healthy and survived the infection
despite having the pathogen present in
their body and we like the superlative
IDEs a new avenue for treating
infectious diseases that will enable us
to promote survival of the patient but
they also in theory should be what we
call anti-evolution proof meaning that
pathogens should not evolve resistance
to such strategies because we're
targeting the the patient and the
physiology that's affected by the
infectious disease without having a
negative impact on microbial fitness I
almost sounds like the microbiome is is
so so complex with hundreds or thousands
of species that how would you ever
disentangle it well enough to be able to
make it into medicine you have to have a
hypothesis you have to conduct clinical
trials
clinical trials have advanced cancer
therapy they've converted HIV infection
from a lethal disease to a completely
treatable disease with long term
step-by-step clinical trials that that's
what the field needs of course that's
what we need in into to restore to have
working antibiotics to develop new
antibiotics as well yep similar things
with the human microbiome to do with
soil as we look at the molecules that
these bugs make and we've in fact found
antibiotics that are effective against
MRSA so these are antibiotics made in
the are bacteria living inside of us
coded by the bacteria living inside of
us so we're certain about its factories
yeah we may not need undergraduates
anymore we may just have to mine our own
microbiome mm-hmm
or the undergraduates to answer the
complexity we also have bacteria phage
in our gut and they are modulating
separate so the fit we have phages that
are attacking our bacteria inside of us
all the time we eat drink phage all the
time mmm ten trillion phage pass through
our gut into our tissues every day every
day every day Wow
so they're everywhere there's tenth of
31 phage on earth so they're everywhere
we eat drink phage all the time so
they're in our gut they're modulating
the organism up and down so you have a
bloom of phage and they're killing a
particular organism if you have a
reduction in in that organism we don't
know what physiological effects it has
on our bodies but it has to have an
effect yeah and and understanding the
modulation of phage and our gut flora is
is another area that people are starting
to look at and then Janelle like that
your own body is then responding to you
know all these different things going on
inside of you I mean absolutely it's a
bi-directional relationship so we're
we're recognizing the microorganisms
that are in our intestine but also some
microbes induced host responses or
immune responses to that are not
effective against themselves but will be
effective against other microbes within
the community so through this
bi-directional communication it goes
back to ecology 101 there they're using
the host to also shape that ecosystem so
I'm gonna open it up to questions in a
little bit but before I do that I just
wanted to get a sense from all of you
about sort of the human side of all this
I mean we talked about how the industry
incentives are all quite perverse and
you know and they're you know that it
takes time and effort to find these
antibiotics or to develop these other
alternatives so are there do you see
changes in a good direction in terms of
you know creating a sort of these
scientific or social customs or
procedures to help get us towards this
better situation where you might use
these things I mean or are we just going
to you know like not be able to define
you know these replacements because
there is enough support for it Marty
what do you think the the bottom line is
that we need to be better stewards of
antibiotics we could create 10 new
antibiotics or 10 new license but unless
we use them better
you know the resistance will get to us
the the bacteria are selected for
resistance so where we have to reduce
the variation in antibiotic use they're
using antibiotics a lot less in Sweden
than they are here people are just as
healthy as we are here there's a lot of
regional variation in antibiotic use
this variation from Doctor to doctor we
the the practice the public have to be
better stewards understand that
antibiotic use has cost we're using it
as if it had no cost so you think that
we could even now I mean not even
talking about these amazing
possibilities that we've just discussed
you think that we could reduce the
amount of antibiotics that patients are
taking and still be that will help us
attack decrease the pressure you know
one of the questions is why did it
c-diff move out of the hospital into the
community why did Mercer move from the
hospital into the general community we
might be able to get it back in right so
you know you were just nodding before I
mean anything I think there's some great
data from antibiotic clinical trials
from 1920s and 1930s where with certain
trials the the group that received the
placebo 80% of them did just fine we can
clear infections on our own we can
survive infections on our own and I
think a lot of times by the time a
patient shows up to the clinic to get
the antibiotics they there are studies
to suggest that they've already cleared
the the infection and now they're just
getting antibiotics because they have
some residual symptoms from the
infection so I completely agree with
Marny that if we can just temper our use
of current antibiotics that will help
significantly and what about I mean
Shawn you were just talking about like
how much money a an antibiotic might
make and how much money is required to
do it so like how do you how do you even
how do you get those things numbers to
balance out
the the the good thing is we've seen
this tremendous effort in the past
decade to try and solve the discovery
problem we still need more money there
but we clearly see there's global
impetus to say we need more antibiotics
maybe there I think there are 50
recognized major efforts in the past
decade to support antibiotic discovery
internationally so I see that's going in
the right direction I really do I don't
know that it's gonna happen fast enough
will ever get enough money but that's in
the right direction but it's the
post-antibiotic issue not only are used
but how do we market it how do we how do
we let those things survives I still
think we have a lot of hard thinking to
think about how how we're gonna do that
and I don't think we have it we have a
solution we have great examples we can
go to there are lots of things that
countries do to put things in reserve
you can say our army is in reserve until
we need it right we pay a lot of money
for that why not think of same models
for antibiotics that we have them
develop there in reserve we pay for them
prior to their use before we need them I
mean there's a lot of thought that has
to go into that but to me that's where
the gap is at the moment we need more
money for development of antibiotics we
see money flooding in we still need more
but there's really still this question
of how do we use them afterwards and how
do we finance them that worries me what
might help is the the fact that we've
been using for years and decades
broad-spectrum antibiotics and they're
killing everything and the reasons for
that is one if you're sick you go to the
hospital and the clinician needs to know
what he's going to treat you with if he
doesn't know the bug that's causing the
infection he has to give you something
that's broad-spectrum if we had
Diagnostics at the bedside so someone
comes into the hospital and we know
exactly what organism is causing the
infection you can treat with an
antibiotic that is specific for that
organism would have very little effect
on your normal floor but we're not at
that point we're getting close the
hospitals now can identify the organism
fairly quickly but are they quickly
meeting power in its time scale ok hours
we're hours from days to hours and if
that if you can do that then you have
antibiotics that are more channeled to
the organism that you're killing which
would cause less side effects and I
think that that might be a way to to
survive this type of
issue that we're having right now but
and then what about serve these less can
we'll call them less conventional things
like phage therapy or using license or
so on do you in terms of getting like
regulatory approval for these things do
you do you do you think that that is
able to move forward quickly enough or
or are we do we need a better way to
sort of like have take in new ideas and
try to get them approved to be used
Wyson therapy has been quite successful
in moving through the system phase
therapy has an issue this phase therapy
is a concoction of many phase to control
a particular infection and since you
could make a cocktail I can make a
different cocktail to cause the same
infection there's no IP so there's no
incentive to develop phage therapy it
does work to some degree but there's no
incentive there but if you have a define
molecule then that I think that the
pathway to get it out out the door is
quite good so Joe I'm just curious are
you when you look ahead fifty years
do you see they they serve the dark
picture they recast earlier or do you
are you optimistic
I mean what's I'm always the optimist
but I also have to be tempered by the
fact that we developed a plan for
antibiotic development and stewardship
when I was in the White House and there
were some really simple things in there
that could have been done like
stewardship of antibiotics and hospitals
so CDC has an eight-point plan of what
hospitals are supposed to do we found
that only 50 percent of hospitals in the
United States followed that very very
simple plan like having a strategy drink
antibiotic use in the hospital training
personnel in antibiotics it it was
really kind of depressing and appalling
and we you know identified all the
things mentioned here and then many
others that we need to steward the
antibiotics use them less have better
Diagnostics so that we know when to use
them and we don't even use the tools
today that we have like Diagnostics I've
I've done this survey completely
unscientific I shouldn't even talk about
it but it's my little way of
keeping tabs on the docs I asked in my
lab when people go for a sore throat go
to the doctor what do they do and ten
years ago there was never a test they
just gave them the antibiotics in every
case and then slowly we started seeing
the strep test strep throat tests being
used but even today fewer than half are
getting a test before they get
antibiotics that just seems
irresponsible to me any guesses why I
mean what do you mean your doctor I mean
why I mean it's a problem of
transparency the medical profession and
the public overestimate the benefit of
antibiotic and they underestimate the
cost the effects of antibiotics and so
we have we have to fix that and I really
agree about narrow spectrum antibiotics
you know and and as the Senate and a
boxer are falsely inexpensive why why
give someone a $500 or $5,000 antibiotic
when you can treat them with a
five-dollar antibiotic so the markets
broken but we need to use tax money just
like we need to use tax money to buy
interstate highways that that's a public
in a box or public good we have to
invest in in in antibiotics that will
protect our future as as a public good
great okay so we have microphones
pushing right in the back there I just
have two quick questions so first one
being how advanced and what is the
percentage accuracy on these diagnostic
tools can they either be improved or is
it just because these current
antibiotics so cheap they're just not
getting that much visibility and my
second question is are there currently
government programs that are in place
are in the pipeline and the reason I ask
this is because they're orphan diseases
out there that don't have a large market
either but yet there are a lot of
government programs that incentivize the
innovations for the space so I'm
wondering if that's something that's
happening a pipeline right now that will
encourage innovation in the space great
so let's say let's take these one at a
time so Vince maybe you could start us
off in terms of the Diagnostics is it
just a case that we already have really
good diagnosis because
just not being used enough or are there
a possibility to develop new kinds of
technology to really get these things
identified fast well right now they're
doing it by DNA analysis so how does
that work
you just get a number of organism a few
organisms from a swab mm-hmm and they
can take and put it extract the DNA and
put it through a machine and identify
certain genes that certain pathogens
have they can do that within hours
sometimes they'd have to grow the
organism very first only a few
generations to get more organism so they
can extract more DNA but it's quite
quite accurate it just takes a little
more time you it's not at the bedside
it's a few hours but it's better than
what we used to have its overnight we'd
have to culture it let the growth
organism grow overnight and then even
another test usually two days before you
get the identification when you say at
the bedside are you saying I mean like
you know our doctor comes ER nurse comes
and like takes your temperature at the
bedside takes your blood pressure at the
bedside are you saying well like a rapid
strep test is the sense at the bedside
you can swab the throat and put it into
a solution that digests the organism and
they have an antibody that identifies
okay a molecule on that organism you
could do that within 20 minutes you get
the results of that experiment that's at
the bedside we're not there yet but
we're close and our hospitals like how I
mean yeah it sounds from your from your
survey I would guess that maybe
hospitals are a little slow to really
snap up these the best of these
Diagnostics definitely some are and then
some aren't just like the the simple
practices to reduce antibiotic
resistance which don't cost any money in
in most cases some adopt them and some
don't yeah and money I mean most
antibiotics used in the United States in
most countries are used in outpatients
they're not used so the focus 90% of the
antibiotics are used in the outpatient
90% yeah and and most of the antibiotics
are used for upper respiratory
infections which we know that a big
fraction are viral and are not bacterial
at all so viral infections don't respond
to antibiotics so we need a rapid
diagnostic that will tell whether that
out pay
walking in has a viral infection or
becareful so like we had in the doctor's
office well we had that tool we could
eliminate a lot of unnecessary
antibiotic testing one of the problems
is that the antibiotic cost five dollars
the test might cost $500 to our health
system isn't manat working okay so after
we get 60 and a back problem we'll fix
the healthcare system right first one is
at the same time anyway the second
question was about what what are what
are theirs are there any special
government programs that are actually
like trying to push you know research
about resistance forward with without so
as you mentioned I'm I'm on this
commission that that Jo was involved in
setting up called pat carb which is
President Obama set it up by executive
order and and our mandate is to combat
antibiotic resistant bacteria and we
have five different areas surveillance
stewardship new Diagnostics new
therapeutics and international efforts
working with other countries so as as
part of these and and the executive
order monies have gone into something
called Barda which is to develop new
antibiotics to put money in to make it
more economically viable to develop
antibiotics to look at antibiotics like
orphan diseases as well they're they're
special stipulations that make it more
attractive for companies to to make
products for orphan diseases great any
more questions
it's prevention still a big thing in
terms of the washing of the hands thing
that's still the best thing yes I have
one little version that I try not to
touch anything when I go to the men's
room does that work just so soap and
water works there's no question but on
the other hand there are all these
antibacterial products that are killing
the good bacteria good bacteria help
protect us against the bad bacteria
against the invader so
are they doing more good or good doing
more harm and I don't know either these
things have hardly been tested and the
people who make them aren't particularly
interested in testing so we should we
should just talk a little bit about I
mean we're talking a lot been talking a
lot about the gut but the skin is
covered in bacteria right like and it's
a completely different flora than we
have in our gut or a mouths or years in
fact the two hands differ left and right
so and are they are they are they doing
are they doing good things for me right
now yeah they're protecting your skin
just like they protect any surface
they're on there good guys you have to
get used to this respect for the
microbes okay okay I can handle this and
so so if you use these sort of hand
sanitizers with the antibacterials there
are times to use them in the hospital
it's very important to use them because
you have a lot of bad bacteria
transmitting in hospitals so washing the
hands in a variety of different ways is
important and during flu season it's
very important because flu is
transferred by people's hands but if you
take all that collectively maybe that's
three percent of the time the other
ninety seven percent of the time the
benefit is just leaving our microbes
alone biggest thing any of us can do is
treat our flu symptoms very respectfully
stay home not so you don't transmit it
wash your hands with soap Purell won't
help with flu but that much but you
certain oh well yeah good are you saying
oh yeah you get a vaccine that's right
and because I think more antibiotics are
given for flu-like symptoms that turn
out to be viral but we don't have the
test to prove that then probably any
other disease so I think if we kept the
flu under control and that can be
controlled just by behaviors and washing
hands and breathing in people's faces
without are usually November or December
till early March this you have to
realize that 90% of infections come in
through
mucus membranes not coming in on your
hands they're coming in through mucous
membranes your eyes your of your genital
tract so when you touch something that's
contaminated you're not getting infected
through your skin it's when you touch
your nose or you touch your mouth that
the organism then gets in that's how it
gets in you have to have a wound your
skin isn't the only other way it's a
wound resist you're bringing the
organism from where the other whatever
you picked up and you touch your nose
and how many times you touch your nose
in your mouth about 12 times an hour for
the average person Wow
in the back there because you were using
bacteria no because you were developing
and what he got penicillin and oil which
came from soil back here and therefore
the soil bacteria had a natural built-in
resistance to the compound you were
using question is it possible to
synthetically generate proteins or
protein analogues which would bind
decides or which interfere in other ways
with mechanisms for which things have
not developed resistance to because they
weren't they aren't actually naturally
occurring equivalents of penicillin yeah
that's actually an interesting point is
that I think they've done studies right
where like they would look at old soil
and actually actually find that there
were some resistance resistant microbes
like before the invention of antibiotics
all right that's right they're all over
my my group has studied site in Alaska
that's essentially as pristine as you
can find a site on earth and it has very
little exposure to antibiotics and we
find a large array of antibiotic
resistance genes we also found that when
sin purely synthetic antibiotics have
been introduced on the market resistance
has developed even faster in some cases
into the the naturally occurring ones
penicillin has been on the market for
what 60 or more 70 years and it's still
useful some of the the synthetic
antibiotics can't even be used anymore
because there's so much resistance so
we're dealing with revolution I think
that's the answer to the question of why
there's no universal cure or prevention
because we're dealing with evolving
organisms I guess the lesson is that
bacteria are pretty awesome
they really are yeah all right well
let's give a hand for our panelists
thank you
you
[Music]